rushing in DC for about an hour Charlie
caption has been both a participant here
at New America Foundation programs but
also a speaker for for a long time and
you know in the world of foreign affairs
and foreign policy as many of you are
aware and you're all part of it there
are days when you can feel good like
you've put something new and fresh on
the table and there are other days when
you feel like a lemming running off the
cliff with a lot of other people that
are thinking the same thing and the
Council on Foreign Relations is just
great institution has a great stable of
scholars nonetheless deserves a
reputation of being involved I remember
this weekend there was a show sponsored
by MSNBC and it was a war game exercise
featuring less gelb the president the
Council on Foreign Relations as sort of
the National Security Advisor Wendy
Sherman Bruce Stokes's wife in fact we
used to be counselor to Madeleine
Albright served the Secretary of State
in this exercise james Woolsey who's
been crying foul about Saddam Hussein
for a long time served as the Secretary
of Defense and there were a number of
other cast of characters and it occurred
to me that we've you know really come
full circle now that we have the full
celebrities ation of certain policy
practitioners on MSNBC sponsored by a
think tank like the Council on Foreign
Relations and it all seems kind of neat
and exciting like this is you know a
more boring version of West Wing but but
you know that people are in there sort
of thinking about how these people might
make decisions and there might be value
in what they do but if you read Charlie
captions new book the end of the
American era u.s. foreign policy and the
geopolitics of the 21st century you see
a very very different kind of
perspective than when we saw on this
MSNBC show of the weekend which rather
than having these sort of moment by
moment blips about which direction we
might go and what the interaction
produces caption in my view provides a
real let's take a step back let's get
out of the lemming going over the cliff
mode and let's ask some fundamental
questions about the nature of American
power about history and context which I
think are quite important and
provocative and so I mean no means no
way mean to criticize the CFR in terms
of this but
to have such a provocative book come
from the Council on Foreign Relations
today in part from support i think is
very very important Charlie caption has
served as a visiting scholar at harvard
university center for international
affairs at columbia university's
institute for war and peace studies as
well as the International Institute for
Strategic Studies in London he's
currently a senior fellow at the Council
on Foreign Relations and he was director
for European affairs on the National
Security Council during the Clinton
administration before joining the
National Security Council caption worked
in the u.s. Department of State on the
policy planning staff he is author of at
least four books already now this is the
fifth including Atlantic security
contending visions nationalism and
national nationalities in the new Europe
the vulnerability of empire and the
Persian Gulf and the West I also
neglected to say that he's professor of
International Affairs now at Georgetown
University is a good friend provocative
thoughts Charlie caption thanks very
much Steve for the for the kind
introduction and for opening up your
Institute for a discussion this
afternoon I appreciate the invitation
thanks to all of you for coming and also
to see span for for covering this and I
you know I welcome all of you here in
part because if my book is intended to
do anything it's to help stimulate a bit
a debate in this country about foreign
policy and about grand strategy because
I think it's a debate that we were not
having at all prior to September 11 to
some extent we're having a little debate
after September 11 but it is a skewed
one where I don't think all the issues
are being put on the table so in that
sense I really am here to to have a
conversation with you about the big
issues of the day and see if we can't
get some of the some of the topics that
are necessary to guide American foreign
policy kind of flesh them out a little
bit in the next hour or so I think that
there are three pieces to the
conventional wisdom in this city that
are guiding our foreign policy and those
three pieces of the conventional wisdom
are first that this is the American era
that America remains uncontested in
terms of its military its economic
supremacy and that nobody is going to
catch America for a long time to come
second piece of the conventional wisdom
is that this is a relatively good thing
especially if you happen to live in
America as many of us do and it's a
relatively good thing because in a world
with only one pole of power you take off
the table what most bedevils statesman
throughout history and that is
competition among competing polls the
great Wars throughout history have
broken out when great powers are
contending for primacy and they go after
each other if there's only one poll
there's no contention for primacy we win
by default so it's a desirable a stable
international order and then the third
piece of the conventional wisdom is
about the stability the durability the
longevity of American uni polarity
American primacy and here I think most
people believe that this era of American
supremacy will define this century will
last at least through the middle of this
century and perhaps to the end and
that's because if you look at the
numbers are military spending our GDP
our cultural reach nobody seems to be
getting close to be able to being able
to take us on and I think that
perspective about durability and
longevity informs our grand strategy in
the sense that the Bush administration
is pursuing as it has said in its
security doctrine a strategy of
preeminence where we will be so far
superior to the rest of the world that
no one will even think about taking us
on and it is that perspective that
provides this sense of overweening power
plus unilateralism we can do what we
want and everyone else will either
follow or get out of the way
I actually share the conventional wisdom
in two respects one that America remains
at the top for now that this is still a
global system defined by American
primacy and to that that's a relatively
good thing from the perspective of
international stability I believe a
world with one pole of power even though
not an egalitarian world is a better
world than with two three or four poles
of power because that contention for
primacy that causes great Wars is held
in abeyance but where I depart
fundamentally from the conventional
wisdom is how long this era of primacy
is likely to last and therefore I differ
with the Bush administration and the
conventional wisdom on what we should do
with this moment of primacy how we
should wield our power to what end and I
believe that our position of primacy is
already beginning to dwindle is already
coming undone and that this decade is
really a switching decade in which the
global system is going to move from a
system defined exclusively by American
primacy to one in which power will
diffuse to other quadrants to it in
which there will be other voices that
need to be contended with on the
international stage and as a result I
think the central challenge for
Americans in this sent in this decade
will not be how to preserve preeminence
how to exert our primacy but how to
prepare for that transition to a world
of multiple centers of power and how to
get there peacefully and the policy
outcomes that I would advocate are far
different from those that the Bush
administration is pursuing that is to
practice restraint rather than to exert
primacy to build institutions rather to
undermine them because we will need them
ourselves by 2010 or so when we are no
longer to have our way as often as we
get it today let me focus on the three
reasons that I think American primacy
will be short-lived first the rise of
Europe and integrating European Union as
a political counterweight to the United
States
second the erosion of what I would call
liberal internationalism in the United
States that is a move away from a belief
in rural and governance through
compromise and institutions to both
unilateral list and neo isolationist
extremes and that will expedite the
erosion of American primacy because it
will alienate other centers of power
through unilateralism through a
stiff-necked gold alone attitude and at
the same time we are going to be
retrenching from certain parts of the
world pulling out Neal isolationist
instincts which will effectively
diminish our control over certain parts
of the world and then the third argument
that I want to discuss with you has to
do with the rise of the digital era and
the extent to which contra to Francis
Fukuyama and others we are not really
seeing the end of history the arrival at
some final end stage we are seeing the
close of the industrial era the opening
of the digital era and that is a
fundamental shift in the underlying mode
of production that rather than bringing
us to some stable end state is really
the opening of a new uncertain and
uncharted historical era which I think
will profoundly change our political and
geopolitical lives so let me take five
minutes or so to expand on those three
themes the rise of Europe the erosion of
liberal internationalism in the United
States and the onset of the digital era
and what some of its implications might
be the perspective that I bring to the
table and thinking about Europe is a
conceptual and historical one and that I
share the perspective of many in this
city that if you take a snapshot of
Europe today you see Tony Blair going
off this way siding with Bush you see
the French heading this way wanting to
sort of turn the EU into an instrument
of power projection you see Schroder
going off the German Chancellor with his
own views about the war in Iraq and it
seems like a mess but I think if you
step back from a snapshot and say what
process is Europe engaging in whereas
Europe headed you come up with a very
different picture
and just to provide a little bit of
historical perspective we Americans tend
to assume that this country has been
centralized with a strong federal
government and a strong national
identity forever because we grew up in
such an America but that's a relatively
recent phenomenon throughout most of the
19th century we Americans debated should
we have a single currency how do we
bring down barriers to trade between the
states should we have a national
identity that competes with the
loyalties and identities of the separate
states should we let the federal
government raised a major army or should
the states fight our wars with their
militias in other words until really the
beginning of the 20th century the United
States was a fragmented Federation or
Confederation struggling to come
together as a unitary entity struggling
to find a voice and to project its power
geopolitically and that really didn't
happen outside our own neighborhood
until the late 1890s after the
spanish-american war we then took the
Philippines wom Hawaiians colonies we
began to come online as in great power
but that's a hundred and twenty years
after we started life as a confederation
in 1781 these things take time Europe is
now about 50 years old it has a single
currency it has a single market it is
increasingly passing power away from the
national capitals up to Brussels there
is now a constitutional convention
taking place they are debating having a
directly elected chief executive they
are debating having a secretary of
Foreign Affairs for Europe as a whole so
in what what I think we are seeing is
Europe gradually begin to turn the
corner from an entity exclusively
concerned about its own internal
construction to an entity that is
beginning to say we want to place in the
world and so I think what you're seeing
is a reversal of history during the 19th
century America came together as a
federation it arrived on the world scene
and it said Europe move over make room
we've arrived what I think is happening
today Europe is slowly coming together
gradually knitting together at several
separate national States into
Confederation and it's saying to Uncle
Sam move over make room and the United
States at least up till now is none too
interested in seating its position of
primacy and making room for an emerging
second pole of power in the globe let me
just offer a few pieces of data to
buttress this more historical and
conceptual interpretation one Europe's
GDP is about eight point five trillion
America's is roughly ten trillion with
EU expansion and growth rates in EU that
could be roughly equal to America's the
two may well pull even in economic terms
during the course of this decade we've
already seen the Euro rise against the
dollar as investment flows have gone
back to Europe after the bust of the
economic boom that was here in the 1990s
including some entrepreneur capital
venture capital which may increase
internet penetration rates in Europe and
increase efficiency and productivity and
I think what regret we will gradually
see over this decade is the Euro
gradually come to rival the dollar as a
global reserve currency the euro is
already taking over Central Europe in
other words the dollar is leaving EU
Russia trade is now denominated in Euros
not dollars and so I think we're
graduating to be moving back to a world
that looks more like the 1930s when the
US Federal Reserve and the Bank of
England because the dollar and the pound
sterling where the dominant currys went
head-to-head and during that time they
didn't do a very good job of
coordinating their policies indeed the
economic turmoil of the 1930s was a key
factor in the onset of geopolitical
instability and war so I think we're
moving it from a position of one captain
at the helm to a position of to the US
Federal Reserve and the European Central
Bank and we're heading in as a result of
that to uncharted waters second I think
we are seeing a an important and
consequential change in the way that
European elites are legitimating the
European Union among their domestic
populations
for the last 50 years a European leader
whether German or French or Danish would
stand up and say we need the EU to
escape the past we need the EU to leave
World War to World War one the
Napoleonic Wars behind because as long
as we have nation-states we will have
wars that refrain is not being used
anymore and that's because of a
generational shift younger Europeans who
are coming of age after the fall of the
Berlin Wall they don't know World War
two they don't know the rebuilding of
Europe they don't even know a divided
Europe and therefore what you're seeing
is a shift toward selling the EU as an
entity to project Europe's voice on the
global stage creating a counterweight to
the United States it used to be only the
French that would make those sorts of
remarks it's now the Germans Schroder
and his foreign minister Fisher it's now
the head of the EU Commission Romano
Prodi it is the prime minister of Sweden
a country that long ago renounced power
politics person is now calling for the
EU to emerge as a counterweight to the
United States it's now Tony Blair even
as he sides with bush and the war
against terror he calls for the EU that
gradually emerges as a superpower an
entity that can hold its own against the
US this is just beginning this new
rhetoric this new dialog but i think it
is consequential and it will increase
the rift and the competition between the
u.s. and the EU finally we're sitting
the EU move into the military realm
slowly trying to build a minimal force
of 60,000 I think it's going to be rough
i think it's going to be slow in coming
but on the diplomatic front I think EU
has already moved more forcefully to
begin to hold its own replacing the
United States as the main diplomatic
arbiter in the Balkans becoming more
involved in the Middle East peace
process gradually replacing the United
States as the key player in Central
Europe and I even though I think if the
prog summit there was a lot of bells and
whistles and saying we finally have
expanded NATO and we have the central
Europeans joining an american-led
alliance I think
neath the surface what we're seeing is
the United States lose interest in
Europe because Europe is at peace and
wealthy it is decamping from the
continent to prosecute the war on
terrorism and it is really the EU that
holds the cards to the future of Central
Europe and Eastern Europe so in that
sense we are seeing a very significant
shift away from American control of the
globe strategic heartland of Eurasia to
one that ultimately will be fall into
the responsibility of the European Union
so what I think we're seeing today is a
division of a unitary West into one of
North American and European halves a
West dominated by Washington is turning
into a West in which there will be two
voices one in Washington and one in
Brussels plus voices from the European
capitals and in that sense it's going to
be a West that operates very differently
than in the past and I would only point
to the pupils that that Steve mentioned
to show how far the rift seems to be
going in terms of increasing
anti-americanism a sense that the
Europeans are going this way and the
Americans are going this way who would
have thought that a german chancellor
who was lagging in the polls would run
for reelection on the basis of a quiet
anti-american campaign calling forth the
resist america card and he would win and
almost every german analyst i know says
that Schroeder one for one reason
because he played that card deftly so I
think it tells you how much the world
has changed when Germany are perhaps our
closest ally for the past 50 years is
now heading in a direction in which
resisting America is a central part of
its political dialogue of its domestic
narrative I I think that we're therefore
in a world in which NATO is on its last
legs in which there will be increasing
divergence over values not because those
value divergences weren't there before
but because they're being politicized
the death penalty us energy consumption
America's aversion to international
institutions
let me now segue to the second issue and
that is American internationalism
because i think that the US and the EU
will inevitably become competitors but
whether they also become adversaries
depends upon America and how we wield
our power and what I see happening in
this country is as I mentioned the
erosion of liberal internationalism and
the shift to both unilateral lyst and
neo isolationist extremes and I think
that's happening for powerful
geopolitical political and demographic
reasons many of us know a lot about
American foreign policy from 41 to today
and very little about American foreign
policy from 1781 to 1941 to go back and
look at that earlier period we are a
country that has really gravitated to
isolationism in unilateralism from day
one as our founding fathers told us to
because they said we have a natural
isolation we can capitalize on that
security with big oceans on either side
small neighbors to the north and south
and we also believe in American
exceptionalism the idea that we really
don't want to engage in the world but if
we do we'll do it on our terms we'll do
it as we see fit and that's why the u.s.
basically stayed out of great power
politics for most of its early decades
and when it did engage it did so in its
own way it backed away from the League
of Nations precisely because a lot of
American populace said we will not
submit our will to an international
institution we Americans fought hard for
our independence and our sovereignty and
we're not going to give it back to some
international institution Roosevelt
comes along World War two comes along
and he sells liberal internationals into
the American people with the backdrop of
World War two but he succeeded because
he reached out he built coalition's
across region he reached out to the
Republicans and fought against
isolationism in unilateralism and he got
the Senate almost overwhelmingly to
approve us participation in the UN at
the end of the war and then we had Nazi
Germany Imperial Japan the Soviet Union
that kept us on that course throughout
most of the
and half of the 20th century what I
think has happened since the end of the
Cold War is a return back away from
liberal internationalism to this more
deeply rooted isolationist and
unilateral lyst political culture that
has been very much part of American
history and so I think 1781 to 1941 may
be a much better indicator of where
we're headed the nineteen forty one to
two thousand think where we were before
September 11 and I know everything is
now terrorism but remember that from
january 22 sep tember 10 we saw two
extremist wings of the Republican Party
duking it out the neoconservative wing
that was about American primacy forever
essentially recreating the world in
America's image and the heartland
conservative wing that wanted nothing to
do with running the world in America's
image it was about keeping our powder
dry pulling out of the Balkans getting
out of the Middle East peace process
focusing on the Western Hemisphere 19th
century Heartland conservative agenda
and every day these two wings of the
Republican Party duked it out then
September 11 comes along cuts the legs
off of the Heartland conservatives we
haven't heard anything about pulling in
our horns for now because we're angry
we're lashing out we're going to get the
barbarians but those Heartland
conservatives are out there there is a
neo isolationism in this country that I
think is growing and strength and as
I'll come to in a second I think
terrorism rather than being an
inoculation against those neo
isolationist voices may ultimately
strengthen them there are those people
in this city who believe that this tug
of war between the neo isolationists and
the neoconservative is a passing
phenomenon of the Bush administration if
Gore had won everything would be fine
once these guys leave office will be
back to the centrist moderate course of
the pre George W Bush era I don't
believe that's the case and I think
there are deeper political and
geopolitical trends taking place that
are pushing American foreign policy in
this direction let me just touch on a
few of them
one is the absence of a transcendent
threat against which we can set our
sights and I keep in mind that this
puncture was effectively tuning out of
foreign policy from the early 1990s
through 2001 with coverage in the press
print and broadcast fallen by fifty to
sixty percent Congress rarely debating
foreign policy and really a sense that
we were no longer engaged in the world
in the same way we were during the Cold
War many people have said that terrorism
is an antidote to unilateralism and to
neo isolationism but I think in some
ways it reinforces both we've seen that
since sep tember 11 the u.s. very much
going off on its own even when the
Europeans offered help and even though
the neo isolationist voice is for now
quiet my guess is it will slowly come
back in part because of the appeal of
the voice the inner voice from George
Washington and Jefferson and Jackson who
said why should we go around and mess in
other people's hair when it means that
they come and mess up our here and blow
up our buildings so I think as time goes
on there will be a sense that we even as
we go after the terrorists we need to
raise protective barriers we need to
protect ourselves from the dangers of
embroil meant in the world keep in mind
what happened on sep tember 11 other
than the attacks we've closed our
borders we've closed our airports we had
warships and aircraft carriers frigates
along our shores protecting America so
even as we go out as we shouldn't fight
terrorism we are also going gradually to
raise protective barriers against the
dangers second point the fastest growing
part of our country is the agrarians
south and the mountain west precisely
where this more populous heartland
conservative population lives and i
think the george bush was reaching out
to that constituency prior to September
11 because it is his constituency it's
where he comes from there the people who
sent him into office and that's another
reason that I think as we move through
time whether it's the democrats in
office or the republicans in office they
are increasingly going to have to appeal
to that Heartland conservative voice and
that is not a part of the country that
generally supports liberal
internationalism that is more the coasts
the ones who
voted for Gore in the last election and
who also voted for the Democrats in this
last midterm election third I think
we're seeing the return of regional and
sectional divides in this country that
will increase the difficulty of putting
together a moderate centrist
internationalism and in that sense I
believe we're going to looking a little
bit more like yes pre 1941 America where
you have the North and the South
fundamentally divided about foreign
policy and I think this is partly
returning because of the digital era
people now live more where they want to
live than where they have to live and in
that sense we're seeing a cultural and a
regional fragmentation that will make it
more difficult to find that moderate
center and I also think we are seeing a
profound almost revolutionary
demographic shift in this country
towards becoming a largely or
predominantly Hispanic country by the
second half of this century this country
will be about a third Hispanic those
Hispanics tend to reside in country in
states with a large number of electoral
votes Florida Texas California that's
going to radically alter this country in
its foreign policy to states of the
union California and Texas have 86 votes
in the electoral college that's almost a
third of what you need to win the
presidency California is almost already
more than majority Hispanic and Texas is
moving in that direction and that says
to me whether you're a Democrat or a
Republican you want to win the white
house you need to carry the Hispanic
vote we don't know a lot about how
Hispanics view foreign policy because we
don't have good public opinion data on
it but to the extent that we do they
care much less about the traditional
agenda alliances defense and much more
about Western hemispheric issues Mexico
Central Europe education trade with
Central Europe excuse me Central America
so in that sense I think we really are
going to see a country that becomes much
more Western Hemisphere akin its
orientation in part because of the
changing nature of our population
finally just as in Europe there is a
important generational shift taking
place so too is there here in America
the people that have been running our
foreign policy Richard Lugar Lee
Hamilton Dick Cheney cut their teeth on
the Cold War they are internationalists
by default this younger generation that
I now teach at Georgetown they're coming
of age after the fall of the Berlin Wall
their key images will not be Munich or
the berlin wall or Soviet tanks their
image that they have in their mind will
be planes hitting the World Trade Center
in the Pentagon what's that going to
make of them I don't know but they will
not be default internationalists of the
sort of the older World War two
generation so again I think we are
moving into an era in which
internationalism will be very different
than it has been in the past let me end
with just a couple quick comments on the
digital era because I want to leave as
much time as possible for discussion
part of the reason that I think the u.s.
is confident about its primacy confident
that it can go out and remake the Middle
East and other parts of the world is a
confidence that we have arrived at the
end of history as fukuyama puts it when
we're going to take the rest of the
world with it and I think that's
excessive confidence that breathes
excessive belief in our own nipples as I
think as we shift from the industrial
era to the digital era the key twin
sisters of the industrial era the
Democratic Republic and nationalism will
change as well and so rather than
arriving at some end state and from here
on out it's smooth sailing as long as we
can keep the terrorists at bay I think
we are entering a period of ethical
change every bit as important as the
shift from the nomadic era to the
agrarian era or the agrarian era to the
industrial era I don't know what that
new era is going to look like it would
be a little bit like us sitting in this
room in the year 1700 and saying what's
the industrial era are going to look
like we wouldn't know but we know that
big changes are afoot and I think some
of the weaknesses we see in American
democracy today the decline of civic
participation the extent to which our
political system has been overtaken by
campaign finance and getting on
television are reflective of this shift
away from a more traditional notion of
American democracy its practiced during
the industrial era too
something new and something that will
change the way we lead our lives let me
end just by touching on three policy
issues what does my analysis suggests
for the direction of this country for
the guiding assumptions for our grand
strategy I would really pass along three
pieces of advice to the people who are
running the country mile or two down the
road and they would be the following one
that America was a general boon to the
world for the last 50 years in part
because we got our internationalism
right we worked through institutions we
were not predatory we did not beat our
chest and run around and tell other
countries what to do and that's because
we told the American people that we
needed institution centrism to work with
others and what I fear is happening
today is that nobody is out there trying
to rebuild that internationalism that
moderate center in this country I don't
see any politician who is really making
that a top priority and I think if you
look at our universities we're not
teaching history if students don't know
about World War two they don't know what
happened in this world then how are we
ever going to get our internationalism
right how we're going to keep this
country on a steady course in the world
so I think a national priority ought to
beat education leadership on the
question of how this country wheels its
power second rather than practicing a
kind of foisting ourselves and in others
leading with this notion of preeminence
I think we should do exactly the
opposite and practice strategic
restraint and compromise a country that
is this powerful risks losing its most
precious commodity commodity which is
its legitimacy the sense abroad that we
are a benign power and not a predatory
power we are in the midst of losing that
if we lose that then a country this
strong is going to scare the rest of the
world and push them away from us that's
exactly what again these pupils are
showing we ought to do what Britain did
to us in the late 19th century see that
we are emerging
make room for others so rather than
trying to boss others around and tell
Europe what to do it seems to me we
ought to step back and say to the
Europeans we welcome a strong EU we want
to work with you because we know we
can't do it alone and finally
institutions institutions do for the
international landscape what
constitutions do for the domestic
landscape they tame it they provide
order and I fear that as we step away
from the ABM treaty the Kyoto Protocol
and climate change the International
Criminal Court as we show ambivalence
about the UN about NATO about other key
institutions we are undermining the
liberal order that we established after
World War Two and we can do so now
because we are still at the top and we
can have our way but I fear that we're
going to wake up in twenty five or
twenty ten and we're going to say you
know we need an institution to manage
global climate change we need alliances
and institutions to manage the workers
we're no longer the big gorilla that we
used to be and if we wake up in 2010 and
those institutions are not there we're
going to have no one but ourselves to
blame and at that point I think America
would find the world a very lonely in a
very dangerous place so it seems to me
we are at a critical switching point
that we ought to open our eyes and see
that the world is changing before us and
work as hard as we can to prepare for
what I see as a very dangerous but also
a period of opportunity and that is the
shift away from American primacy toward
a world of multiple centers of power
thank you thank you joy I'm gonna take
questions but I'm going to launch one
first and when I do I take questions
I'll ask the question or to make it a
question and to identify yourself in
affiliation if you would for Charlie let
me um I hate to do this because I love
the book so much but play the role of
devil's advocate for a minute
you don't if Walter Russell Meade were
here Walter is a colleague of Charlie's
at the Council on Foreign Relations
wrote a book called special Providence
which looked at strains of American
foreign policy divided them up between
wilsonian Hamiltonian jacksonian and Who
am I missing is if this afforded in
there a Jeffersonian I think yeah and
and but but when he began this project
many of the people that he brought to
sort of critique his book were naysayers
about the history of American foreign
policy and he was saying we'll look at
American look at our success look where
we are in the world and and said you
know aren't those people that are
looking for in policy far too dismissive
about the success and strategy and style
of American foreign policy that that
would be part 1 part 2 is regarding the
Europe why not let Europe just just go
its direction it largely shares with
some exceptions which you pointed out
like death penalty and others largely
shares the value structure generally
that we consider that many people
consider to be the value structure in
the United States why not have have a
bit of competitive zeal there because
the consequences of that are minor and
then then challenge the international
system or walk away from it because it
was fixed for a different world Europe
is fixed and approach a big problems
like the Middle East and Africa and and
and maybe come back and reorient the
international institutional side of that
to fit a very different reality what's
what's wrong with that picture and could
that not be behind the thinking of
strategists in the Pentagon and White
House today on the first question I
think my colleague and friend Walter
meat is right the US has practiced
foreign policy with great success since
world war two with some exceptions but
in general I think we got it right I
think that we can no longer assume that
that will continue in part because we
got it right because we had an other
because there was a Soviet Union
Imperial Japan a Nazi Germany that
pressed this country into being engaged
in the world and are responsible and in
a measured fashion and I think that if
you look at
bigger picture we didn't always get it
right and the more i read about American
history say in the 20s and 30s how hard
Wilson worked to sell the League of
Nations to the American people and how
desperately he failed sends to me
warning signs about where we are headed
and a lot of the same arguments that
were used to shoot down the League of
Nations you here today the same
institutions that the Europeans want to
try to tame America and provide order
are the very ones that the American
populace see is unacceptable
encroachments upon American sovereignty
and so I just fear that we have had
success but we're complacent we're going
to continue to have it we need a
national debate if we're going to get it
right and I don't think we're having
that as far as the EU goes I think that
to some extent there will be a rift
there's nothing either side can do about
it it's the way of the world when Europe
arises it's going to say we want more
voice it will set it strength against
the United States because we're number
one nothing we can do about it the key
though in my mind is we need to make
sure that as that happens we do our best
not to let it turn adversarial because
if that happens I think then we're going
to be in a world where no we're not
going to be at war with Europe but most
key international institutions were
stumble because they work because of an
eu-us partnership if that partnership
goes awry we're going to have
differences about everything the Middle
East the IMF the World Bank currency
trade and in that sense we potentially
are moving into a dangerous world and
that's why I think that we're being
short-sighted by missing the picture
it's not China it's not Islam that in
this decade is going to be the real
challenger to American primacy it's
Europe
yes right here I've filled arch with
distance in center Charlie if we had a
national debate on foreign policy what
would it take for you to win what kind
of disaster is what kind of groundwork
definitely I think that the challenge of
educating cajoling building a centrist
internationalist coalition today is huge
in part because even though we don't
have a big threat out there we do have
the terrorist threat but I think it's
the wrong threat for building
internationalism because it's elusive
it's hard to get at one day it's here
the next day it's here one day we're
told that the country's at war and we
need to tighten our belts and get ready
the next day we're told please go
shopping at the malls please take a
vacation because we nobody's on our
airplanes so I think the American public
is getting mixed signals about what's
going on out there and therefore i think
there's no replacement for someone sort
of standing up and saying listen
terrorism is important but so is
everything else that was on the agenda
before September 10 right now we're
terrorism 365 days a year 24 hours a day
and I fear that that's pushing us off
the deep end that's creating a world in
which the views that we have as a
country both elite in public and the
views that the rest of the world have
shared little common ground and that's
that's quite worrisome so I guess the
what I would say did you know as a short
answer education in particular history
get politicians who are willing to stand
up and talk about the importance of
these issues because if left to its own
devices we will drift to isolationist
and unilateral istic streams I think
it's for ordained and and and get people
to try to create programs on this the
only place i've seen it is yale they
have created a new certificate on grand
strategy which i think is great but it's
a drop in the bucket in terms of what's
needed to keep this country on course
for nick berry foreign policy forum a
defining moment is around the corner the
possibility of war with iraq how would
that war whether we fight it or not
affect the three factors you mentioned
changing primacy i think that how that
war is fought whether it goes through
the UN and enjoys the legitimacy of a
resolution and the approval of allies is
critical and i think that so far so good
and i have to give the bush
administration credit for taking the
issue to the UN and for continuing to
work through those procedures because i
fear that if that doesn't happen that
this sense in the rest of the world that
we've gone unhinged will be more intense
and that will separate us even more from
the world so the first thing I'd say is
do this right through international
institutions and through international
law the other point I'd make is that I
think we ought to have a debate in this
country and the government in Congress
about whether we ought to really be
committed to invading the country
toppling the regime and occupying Iraq I
worry that that is to go too far in part
because the key issue here is weapons of
mass destruction and I wonder whether we
can't get those weapons through
airstrikes and covert operations and
surgical attacks as opposed to occupying
the country and part of my worry here is
that the Bush administration will
overreach they will in some ways do what
Wilson did demand too much of the
American people and as a result have a
backlash as I think the Iraqis may well
dance in the streets for two to three
days but only two to three days and then
they're going to shoot at us and if body
bags start coming home because we think
we're going to go to the Middle East and
everyone's going to become a liberal
Democrat overnight and a pluralist Islam
will emerge think we're kidding
ourselves so in that sense my advice
would be aimed low don't overreach get
rid of the weapons of mass destruction
but don't delude yourself into thinking
it
can occupy a rock and turn the Middle
East around towards some benign
prosperous democratic region yes right
over from the State Department you
mentioned the tendency of the of Europe
to grow in power but the other one of
the other pieces of information is the
declining growth rates for European
population and that seems to run against
what you're saying so I'm wondering
whether you factor that into your
calculations and what kind of effect
that will have I would seem to reduce
the strength of Europe just so sees the
c-span audience can hear thanks for 18
point as Charlie's model assumed what's
going on with global demographic shifts
getting very important no question that
if there is a piece of data on the
horizon that should make people wonder
about Europe's future it's the
demographic issue because they have
declining populations pension systems it
will grow boat broke in 2020 because
there'll be too many pensioners and not
enough workers and so yes there is a
problem looming on the horizon I would
make two points though one is that over
the next few decades the EU will still
be a major player economically its
population is already larger than ours
and it's expanding second you're
beginning to see changes in EU law to
try to deal with this problem in terms
of portability of pensions increase in
labor mobility to try to get people to
move around the Union and finally and
most importantly I think the EU will
ultimately bite the immigration bullet
because they have no option and that
means first of all bringing more and
more workers in from Central Europe
where there is a younger population and
ultimately bringing in more from Turkey
and other Muslim countries because
that's where the warm bodies are that's
not going to be easy because the EU is
not good at integrating non-europeans
into the union but i think that the
pressure to do so is so profound that
ultimately that is how they will deal
with this demographic shortfall
yes andrew patterson environment of
business international if you could
extend your comments people all you have
to yeah if you could extend your
comments on the rift between Europe and
the US over environmental and energy
policy some people have characterized
the stab at Iraq is really driven by the
need for cheap energy and control the
world's oil supplies that's a bit over
simplified but this larger issue of
environmental and energy policy is going
to be a major arena for the rift I think
that you're talking about how do you see
it breaking out I think it's one of the
most intractable and dangerous disputes
because we are miles apart in Europe
there really is a profound sense of the
need to protect the environment that
this is an emergency and you see more
and more smart cars and public
transportation and efforts to protect
forests and parks and in the United
States the opposite is really happening
more and more Americans are buying SUVs
that get have poor fuel efficiency
rather than signing up to these Kyoto
Protocol or other initiatives we're
talking about drilling new oil wells and
the Alaskan wilderness and I think at
heart there is a real difference in
political culture we still have a bit of
the frontier spirit in this country that
we want to drive our big cars and to
hell with the rest of the world if we
emit twenty-five percent of the world's
greenhouse gases even though we have
four percent of the population that's
America that's all right the economy so
I never liked that analogy but the 911
crisis would seem to reinforce the
things that you're talking about yeah I
just mean I don't know if you've been in
Europe recently but there is a palpable
sense of estrangement a palpable sense
that we don't know what's going on over
there in North America but they seem to
be going off the deep end our views
toward Europe are the same there was
just a conference here a few weeks ago
at AEI american enterprise institute
called what's wrong with europe and so
there is I think a sense that there is
this back-and-forth ping-pong game which
could spin out of control if we are not
careful because the European politicians
are already using the American card for
political purposes we're beginning to
see American elite talk about the
Europeans as wimps a nuisance not a
partner and that's dangerous because if
we have one real partner in the world
still it's Europe Zeus tell me honestly
I was wondering I confess I haven't read
your book yet but are there also divided
outside okay bye-bye to comms are there
also internal factors I think that are
going to aid things that could cause
this country to implode someone I'm
thinking about as with any Empire a kind
of decadence and overreaching and
overconfidence you know look at the
things like consumer debt skyrocketed
efes it and these sorts of things that
could aid that versus the external
pressure of the EU etc yeah i mean the
the section of the book that deals with
the digital era is mostly about American
domestic politics and how as we move to
this world where we tend to stay at home
and work from computers don't have as
much contact in terms of the town hall
meeting as we used to that this country
could really be shaken in ways that no
one can can begin to speculate about it
so yes I mean I think we're moving into
a period that's going to be new and
different and we better get ready for
change the one silver lining that I'd
offer up though is that I think that
America is deep-seated historic
ambivalence about engagement in the
world is going to help us in the end
because right now we are in a bit of
what I would call Imperial overdrive and
we you know we think we're just going to
get out there and and we have all this
military power and the rest of the world
is going to get on its knees and say yes
whatever you say that's just not the way
the world works we can have a test now
because Paul Wolfowitz and others thinks
that is the way the world works you get
out there you give commands and everyone
gets out of the way I think if we do
that we're going to provoke the
countervailing coalition that they think
we're going to avoid but at least we
have a test
ace but in the end of the day I think
the American people perhaps over a rock
perhaps over some other issue are going
to stand up and say enough this is not
consistent with American ideals let's
bring home the boys let's let other
people the Europeans handle more of the
burden I think that'll happen and much
sooner than we think I want to get other
questions I want to follow up on one
piece because you're getting off a
little too light on this on the question
about the United States can do things in
the world today that no other nations
can do we can maintain a current account
deficit of an order in magnitude that no
other nation in the world can do without
the IMF coming down on its head or
without its particular economic
situation really going caterwaul key the
United States can do it because of
American power and it can do it because
of its placed in world and we can do it
because the reserve currency is held so
broadly if you begin to undermine that
and you really begin to get a different
driver as you said at the economic helm
the issue is not just battling over
policy it means that the premium that
the dollar that the premium on American
economic behavior in the world will
erode or disappear and that premium is a
measure of the quality of life of
Americans actually and so what I'm
introd is as you put pressure on that
what impact on on quality of life d I
mean that's a massive change actually if
you look at look at the numbers and in
terms of what Americans expect of their
economy and nation right I mean those
are all critical points because even as
we have this sense of triumphalism this
sense of omnipotence there are pretty
potent signs of weakness beneath the
surface in terms of America still living
beyond its means an important capital
from abroad in terms of a situation in
which if the dollar is going to weaken
substantially and it might and perhaps
it probably should it could cause
capital flight it could cause a deep
decline in our equity markets as
foreigners begin to pull their assets
out of the United States and eventually
Americans may find that they simply
can't consume like they've been
consuming and that's going to change the
politics in this country we are still I
think there
much pro free trade still leading the
world and that but that could that could
change if this recession gets deeper and
grows in length and i think that the
real issue here is not just domestic as
if the US begins to exercise less
leadership of the international economy
which i think it will then the
international economy itself will become
more difficult more rocky yes right here
no relevant affiliation but to go back
to the question about demographics and
your comments about non-european
cultures justin is a focus on europe
something of a distraction you're the
european union may assert itself by 2010
but by 2020 if india india or a
Confederated asia or a Confederated
islam which has you know potentially
more resources definitely more people is
that really where we should be looking
rather than kind of an interim your
intramural the spirit dispute with
Europe over the next 10 years I think
you're right in terms of let's extend
the time horizon then others enter the
picture I tended to focus in the book
and in the discussion today on Europe
because I think we're looking right past
that we're missing it and it's a big
issue I think in this decade it is the
critical issue and we need to put more
attention on it if you fast-forward to
twenty twenty or twenty twenty-five then
China is certainly a key player they're
going to be a major world economy may be
a major world military by 2025 but 2025
is a bit far off China's economy today
is smaller than that of California China
in 10 or 15 years will have an economy
the size of Italy so it's out there but
it's not this decade and the other
issues you talk about I think are
equally valid it may well be that by
2025 the EU in the US are coming back
together to deal with China or to deal
with the Islamic world but i think that
the story for now is going to be the end
of this partnership and the sense that
even though many people believe we're
kissing cousins and could never part
ways seems
be happening masa associates an American
company but in your I just would like to
follow up on what he said because the
only time you mentioned Asia was a 150
you mentioned Imperial Japan and that
was it and it looked like the world
consisted of the Atlantic Ocean and the
Pacific never existed but when you look
at economy as a fundamental basis for
power that of course America does not
have such a supremacy it has military
power that can beat up on anybody else
more than one but on economics and
someone mentioned it's only twenty-five
percent and it's a matter of alliances
and in that sense i think that the
alliance between say Japan could be a
swing bolt was Europe Dennis bigger than
United States and with a with a seven
point you mentioned on digital divide in
fact China's growth and India's power is
not that far behind it might not be 2020
might be 2010 so I think it's very
important to figure in Asia and perhaps
with your great analytical power would
you write a book
I'll try to get that out to by Friday I
mean you're a hundred percent right and
Asia is for now a little bit i think in
the doldrums because of the Japanese
economy but it simply reinforces the
central point that I'm making that just
because the United States spends more on
defense than all of the great powers
combined and has 12 or 13 carrier task
forces and most countries have none it
can't run the world because day-to-day
operation of the world system is not
about fighting wars it's about trade
it's about currencies it's about
institutions and if we a lien ate the
rest of the world because we're sort of
going off half-cocked then we're going
to be in deep Hawk and so I think that
if you add Europe already out there and
then you bring Asia into the picture it
simply reinforces this sense that
America should be less cocky about its
omnipotence well Charlie I want to thank
you very much for joining us thank you
very much I will encourage those of you
one who join us on wednesday for the
program on the Pew Research Center study
what the world thinks to join us also
we've made available Olsen's books has
provided the books outside and Charlie
will work his way through the room and
be at the books if you want to get his
signature on on the books thank you all
very much for joining us very much
thanks again thanks students
sir thank you i know you are very happy
about you Charles option is a professor
of international relations at Georgetown
University and a senior fellow at the